[Music]
hi everyone welcome back so I'm really
excited in this lecture to tell you
about one of my favorite algorithms kind
of modern algorithms called robust
principle component analysis so the
regular principle component analysis is
one of the absolute most important
algorithms of the last hundred years you
see this everywhere it's right up there
with the fast Fourier transform is
principal component analysis this is a
cornerstone a mainstay of statistics and
modeling big data so if you're
interested in machine learning Big Data
you've definitely seen principal
components analysis before and you've
probably used it ok and so what we're
gonna talk about today is how can we use
sparsity to improve the principal
component analysis to make it more
robust to outliers to corruption to bad
data measurements and this is based on a
recent paper by can des Lima and right
from 2011 which really beautifully
outlines this theory and shows how to
use it ok and what I'm gonna talk about
in this lecture just as kind of a hook
to get you interested and to kind of get
through the math is this basic problem
here what if we had a picture of a
person we knew it was a person but it
had this kind of big funny mustache or
maybe the person was wearing a hoodie or
trying to disguise themselves and hide
from some security camera can you with
modern robust statistics with modern
tools and kind of machine learning and
an optimization can you figure out what
was under that mask and kind of subtract
off that mustache or that hood so can
you decompose an image into the true
underlying system the underlying
measurement and kind of the mustache and
fake glasses and hood ok and
surprisingly and slightly alarmingly the
answer is in many cases yes you
absolutely can so you can no longer kind
of get the cartoon fake nose and
moustache and glasses and hide from the
cops because based on on pretty recent
advances in sparsity and and robust
statistics you can actually start to
figure out what's under under
disguises very cool again a little bit
alarming but but I'm gonna walk you
through all of this and how this works
okay and there's no magic happening this
only works because I know that I'm
looking for pictures of a person okay I
couldn't so I'll walk you through all of
why this works and how this works and
some of the math under underlying this
in this lecture okay
again this is following chapter three
from our new book by myself and Nathan
Cutts data-driven science and
engineering if you want to read about
this download the PDF here all the code
in MATLAB and Python are on databook UW
comm and on github so you can kind of
walk through these examples yourself
okay and use this I think you should be
using this in your daily life and in
your research this anytime you would use
principal components you should be using
robust principal components okay
so as a little motivation we've seen
before kind of this robust regression
idea so if I'm gonna do a least-squares
regression maybe I have these blue data
points and I want to fit a line to those
data points but maybe I have a really
bad outlier and one measurement that's
way outside of the distribution maybe
someone just messed up the instrument or
kicked the you know kicked the
thermometer or whatever you're measuring
someone just messed up the measurement
here and but everything else is okay and
so we've seen before that even though
there is this true kind of slope this
true fit regression fit for the bulk of
the data if you do something like a
least squares regression this l2
minimising regression then this is gonna
be strongly skewed by this outlier and
it's actually gonna tilt the entire
regression fit to get closer to that
outlier because the sum of the squares
of the error the square of this error is
so much larger than the squares of all
these other little errors okay and so
what this tells you is that standard
least squares regression is very very
fragile or sensitive to outliers it
tilts the whole regression fit and we're
gonna see that that's exactly also true
of principal components but what we've
also seen is that if you use an l1
regression so instead of penalizing the
sum of the squares of the errors UPenn
the sum of the absolute values of the
errors this l1 error norm you get a much
much more robust and faithful estimate
of the original distribution even given
this outlier so it's much more robust
and it has this outlier rejection
property okay so that's exactly what
we're gonna be doing here with this
robust principal component analysis
again you have some cloud of data with
an outlier there is some true
distribution that you're assuming can be
well modeled by a Gaussian by some kind
of tilted stretched out Gaussian which
is the normal principal components
analysis assumption but when you do
standard PCA just kind of vanilla
off-the-shelf PCA that whole
distribution is gonna get again tilted
down to be closer to this outlier it's
gonna tilt and stretch and distort the
distribution because of that one outlier
so again I can't stress this enough
regular principal components analysis it
handles small amounts of like white
noise but outliers and corruption that
are well outside of your distribution
that are kind of really bad measurements
will completely skew your PCA and so PCA
is also very fragile with respect to
outliers and is very sensitive to them
and so what we're gonna see is that this
robust principal component analysis just
like our robust l1 regression is going
to kind of compensate for you knowing
that there's outliers it's gonna use an
l1 penalized regression and it's gonna
fix this this principal component fit
and so you're gonna get much closer to
the true distribution and you're gonna
have a lot more robustness to corrupt
and outlier measurements okay
this is just the cartoon I'm gonna walk
you through the map okay so if we go
back to kind of this original paper this
RPC a work by Kendall's Lima and right
we're still talking about this basic
idea let's say I have a high dimensional
measurement so I always think of
pictures has really really high
dimensional measurements maybe a million
megapixel images a million tall vector
in my world and so we have this
high-dimensional measurement and we know
that some of the pixels are corrupted so
I this isn't animate this is not an
example from their paper they have a
little bit more serious examples this is
a silly example from from our book where
I add this goofy moustache and so you
can see that something like 20% of the
pixels are just completely wrong I've
completely obliterated them and turned
them into just black pixels so that's
kind of what I mean by an outlier or by
a corruption it's not just my face with
some white noise on it
it's just I've erased that information
and it's outside of the distribution of
what a face looks like ok and so the
question is how can we split this X data
into some component that is you know
true and correct and a sparse matrix
with all of these outliers and you can
see that there's a ghost a faint picture
of his face but this is pretty small in
magnitude this matrix is mostly sparse
and mostly it's almost all zeros all of
this stuff is almost zero and then this
mustache is a sparse collection of all
of the corrupt outlier measurements from
the original data so how do i split my
data like this why can i split my data
like this that's that's what I'm going
to talk about and the basic idea is you
couldn't do it if you didn't have a
large library or a large kind of
statistical knowledge of what a human
face should look like ok so you couldn't
do this if you didn't know what a human
face looked like if you didn't have a
training data set so in kind of the
machine learning speak you need a large
training data set to learn the
statistical features of what's in a
human face and then you can do this
robust principal components ok and so
the basic idea this is from the Yale
faces be data set so you have 36
individual people and for each of those
36 people you have 64 images of that
face with different lighting conditions
it's actually a really cool experiment
they built this geodesic dome with all
these cameras and lights rather all of
these lights and then a camera and in
two seconds they would flash all of
these lights and take 64 images to get
all of these different lighting
conditions
so it's a really massive library of what
human faces should look like under
different lighting conditions and the
idea is that if you have that data set
even if one of your images has pretty
bad corruption maybe even if I like
black out 1/2 or 1/4 of these in of
these faces or I put a big curly
mustache on one of them because of these
statistics of this data set you can
essentially separate out the the data
set into what's called a low rank
component that's well described by
principal components and a sparse
component that has all of the outliers
and all of the kind of weird corrupt bad
measurements okay
and there's a lot more depth here so I
do encourage you to read their paper and
read this in Chapter three of our book
if you want to know more or check out
our code I'm just giving you kind of the
highlights right now okay so the basic
idea is that you would take all of these
phases 64 times 36 you would reshape
each of them into a really tall skinny
vector so now you have this massive
massive matrix number of pixels by
number of images and what we're gonna do
is we're going to do this robust
principal component analysis to split
kind of that big big data matrix into a
low rank matrix a matrix that is well
described with principal components with
low variability and this is what's
called our eigenfaces
and so if you take the SVD of your faces
you get these eigen faces that low rank
matrix would have your eigen faces and
then plus a sparse matrix which has all
of the stuff that's not in that
distribution of what if they should look
like like this curly weird mustache that
I added okay and so then that problem is
really actually very simple to write
down we're trying to we're trying to
decompose X into the sum of two matrices
L plus s where L is low rank meaning
it's well described by a few patterns
it's well described by principal
components and s is a sparse matrix with
all of the corruption and outliers and
bad measurements okay but you'll notice
this is not a well posed problem at all
there are infinitely many ways I can
split a matrix X into a sum of two other
matrices this is kind of like I have
n nodes and two n unknowns so it's it's
completely ill-conditioned and under
determined and I there's infinitely many
solutions to this problem but we're
getting really good at that that's
becoming a common theme nowadays in
optimization and statistics and sparsity
and machine learning in general is that
you can solve these ill-posed inverse
problems if you regularize if you add a
penalty term that promotes a single
solution that has the kind of physics or
behavior that you want and in this case
what we actually want to do that the
properties we actually want on L&S is
that we want our L matrix to be low rank
so it's well described by principal
components so we want to minimize the
rank of L we want s to be sparse because
we don't believe that that much of our
image is corrupt so we want s our kind
of corruption entries to be a sparse
matrix and we want to minimize that rank
plus L zero norm of s so that L plus s
adds up to X so that this is true now
this optimization problem here it's
always good to write down what you want
to solve but you can't solve this in any
kind of a computationally efficient way
because this is a highly highly non
convex optimization problem both the
rank and the zero norm are not convex
and so you have no guarantee that you're
gonna find a solution to this you know
before the universe goes cold and so
what the authors of this paper did was
they introduced this convex relaxation
this is what we normally do is that we
we introduce proxies for these norms so
these dorms are non convex and hard to
work with so you introduce proxies of
those norms that are easier to work with
in this case the proxy for rank is the
nuclear norm or the sum of singular
values and the proxy for sparsity is the
one norm or the kind of sum of the
absolute values of the entries of X so
this is a convex optimization problem
you can solve this in a scalable way
that you know works in in a relatively
computationally efficient manner and
what you
get out we'll probably with high
probability it will be promoting low
rank l and sparse s okay so this is how
you actually solve the problems by
running this minimization there's all
kinds of good details in the paper and
in our chapter three about how you would
actually compute this and how you can
write your own code using kind of
alternating Direction methods or
Lagrange multiplier methods to satisfy
this okay but that's what you actually
do is you're trying to find you know a
solution to this ill-posed inverse
problem where L is low rank this
contains all of the patterns in the data
and s is a sparse vector or matrix of
all of the outliers in your data can you
do it you do it this way good so that's
actually basically how it works and in
the original kind of paper where you
have this data set here they actually
applied it to this data set and what
they found was that they were able to
kind of remove shadows from people's
faces so it's a little hard to see but
in some of these you have pretty large
shadows and what they were able to do is
from the limited information that was in
the picture the low rank part they could
subtract off the shadow and show you
what the person's face would look like
in full illumination and then everything
else all of the shadows would go in this
kind of sparse matrix s so that's a
really cool cool demo of how this works
and you can also use it for things like
surveillance or you know if you have a
license plate and you know you have
lines going through it so some of its
occluded you can kind of back those out
possibly you could figure out what's
under you know someone's mask all kinds
of interesting and maybe questionable
technology that can come from this okay
but again it's based on this idea that
you are solving your regularized
optimization problem and that there is a
convex relaxation so that you can do
this on really big data problems okay
good and in the last part of this I just
want to point out that you can also
apply this to fluid flows so fluid flows
and physical systems in general
engineering systems or systems from
science even though they are also very
high dimensional they often have low
dimensional patterns so in fluid physics
we call principal components analysis
orthogonal decomposition P OD the same
basic idea where you can essentially
decompose a very complicated system like
this fluid flow into the sum of only a
few kind of basis flows or eigen flows
so maybe you only need ten
you know principal components to
describe this fluid flow
what Isabelle Sherrill has shown so
Isabelle is a graduate student working
with Brian Paolo G and me what she
showed is that even if you have your
fluid flow data that is massively
corrupted with kind of salt and pepper
white noise it's not white noise salt
and pepper corruption that you can
essentially use this robust principal
components analysis and you can
decompose that into a low ranked fluid
which is kind of the fluid the cleaned
version of the fluid and a sparse matrix
of all the outliers and corruption and
it's important to point out actually
that regular principal components works
quite well for white noise so if you
have a little bit of white noise
everywhere on your data regular
principal components does a good job
robust principal components is when you
have this kind of big corruption and
outliers it's a little hard to tell here
because this is high res but all of
these little salt and pepper errors this
is not white noise added to my field we
basically made these values manually
like negative 10 or +10 so so they're
really really bad outliers and the
original data has been obliterated in
that salt and pepper the salt and pepper
corruption and so you can do this like
then you can actually compute the
principal components or the PID modes so
the true modes this is P OD on the noisy
data this is robust principal components
analysis and what is it bell showed is
that you actually get much much better
kind of decomposition of your flow when
you run this robust defying technique
you can also use this to build models
like these dynamic mode decomposition
models where we know for these periodic
flows all of the eigenvalues of the
system should live on the unit circle in
discrete-time but before doing this
robust filtering step you get terrible
eigenvalues kind of really really bad
eigenvalues after our PCA almost all of
your eigenvalues are where they should
on the unit circle so really great work
by Isabelle you can read about it in
this archive paper she'll have a video
on this soon and I'll put a link up when
when that video is posted kind of
walking through this on many many more
examples last thing I want to point out
I actually talked about this in Chapter
one on the singular value decomposition
when I talked about the Netflix Prize
and correlations in general and so I
thought I would revisit that example
here in the context of robust principal
components analysis so we had the
Netflix prize and matrix completion and
the basic idea here is that you have
this massive imaginary not imaginary
like square root of negative 1 yet this
this massive matrix think about it as a
thought experiment where for every movie
in the database and for every single
person in your subscriber list you had
this matrix of preferences and here I've
simplified it so it's just you know plus
one if you like the movie negative one
if you don't like the movie but notice
and so people you know have different
preferences and of course we believe
that individual people kind of there are
principal components of movie
preferences and movies themselves so
maybe you know the Terminator and Conan
are more similar than the Terminator and
the fantastic mr. Fox right there these
live in a principal component together
and and so do different people and so
the idea here is the the vast majority
of this Netflix matrix is is empty
people haven't rated every single movie
they've ever watched they haven't
watched all the movies or else Netflix
wouldn't be in business right so so the
vast majority of these entries are
unknown and what Netflix and and other
recommender systems would love to do is
infer what do you probably what would
Alice probably think about Pulp Fiction
or what would Bob probably think about
the fantastic mr. Fox so they want to
fill in all of these missing values and
that's a very closely related problem to
the RPC a problem okay so for example
let's just do kind of a thought
experiment here let's look at Dan and
who they have a lot of overlap in in
their data so they both like pulp
fiction and they both like fantastic mr.
Fox one of them doesn't like Conan the
other one doesn't like Dazed and
Confused and so what you can kind of
this is just a guess you can kind of
infer that based on their I'm having
similar preferences some places they
might have similar preferences other
places similarly you can do this on a
column like The Big Lebowski over here
you know for example if if someone like
Bob you know agrees on this movie
I already missing Maya already losing my
what I filled in yeah so if you know if
Bob disagrees with pulp fiction maybe
he's gonna disagree with The Big
Lebowski okay and this is an example
where I kind of did it by hand so this
is a little silly but you can imagine
that if this was a much much much much
much much larger matrix and it's much
sparser there are still all of these
correlations you can still
cross-reference everything it's almost
like a really really high dimensional
Sudoku puzzle okay where you are
cross-referencing thing and trying to
figure out based on someone liking this
and someone liking this what this other
person would like okay but with these
kind of robust statistics techniques and
these regularize solutions for ill-posed
inverse problems and the fact that
patterns exist in your data
there are ways of automating the
solution of this problem and so they're
actually getting quite good at this in
recommender systems they're really
getting good at inferring what would be
what the entries of a mostly sparse
matrix would be assuming that it has low
dimensional patterns okay
so robust principal components analysis
is super useful really important again
you should definitely go check out the
original paper check out Chapter three
in our book where we talk a lot about
and kind of sparsity in general and
robustness and robust statistics and
download the code and try this
yourselves this is really powerful stuff
there's not magic happening here it
seems like magic because this inverse
problem is ill-posed but with the magic
of regularization with a dude
dishes choice rather of regularization
you can do these pretty pretty amazing
things like robust signal decomposition
okay thank you